now thursday morning time for puppy pig
skin picks it is sponsored by subaru of
las vegas
john from the animal foundation good
morning to you sir good morning
this is baby belle she's 10 years old
and she's about 10 pounds
she's a couple pounds overweight okay
but she's a really sweet
wonderful dog a little senior yeah and
so we were just talking about senior
dogs it's so special to be able to give
them a nice home
yes uh if someone has another dog at
home already does she do well with other
dogs
um as far as i've seen yes she interacts
pretty well we don't have a really
big background on her because she came
as a spray but uh her interaction with
other dogs i've seen has been nice
yeah and she is mellow she's very
curious yes
she's adorable really quick best in show
just wrapped up
24 dogs got adopted how was it it was it
was a big success
we'd like to say thank you to everybody
who participated all the donations that
came in
it was a wonderful experience good good
to hear okay
so baby belle it is time we got the
titans at the ravens
this week it is time to make a choice
make a choice
oh she picked the titans thanks baby
belle
her little smile's so cute if you would
like to adopt baby belle
she is available just call the animal
foundation number is there on the screen
and she's a very sweet doggie
nate